while speaking of Elon Musk it brings us
to our final segment Elon Musk says
graduating from a college not needed
they're not for learning Musk the CEO of
SpaceX also said he's going to be dead
before people get tomorrow's based on
past trends that bums me out I wonder if
I'll still be able I really say that
no yeah he said they're not moving fast
enough here you wanna read this let's
say Elon Musk the CEO of Tesla and
SpaceX says said that graduating from
college is not needed and that colleges
and universities are not for learning
he's right he's right
you don't need college to learn stuff
okay must said to satellite 2020
conference in Washington on Monday
everything is available basically for
free you can learn anything you want for
free it's not a question of learning
there's a value or there is a value that
colleges have which is like seeing
whether somebody is there can somebody
work hard at something including a bunch
of sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
and kind of soldier through and get it
done question mark okay he's kind of
complaining about I guess he's saying
what we've basically said in our past
segments yeah hearing it from him
Zachary yeah you know college is just
for for these rich people to make more
money I stupid kids to get messy people
into getting hooked into paying money
further who knows how long oh he goes he
gets brutal on it all right let's say
that's that's like the main value of
college and then you also probably want
to hang around with other people your
own age for a while instead of going
right into the workforce so I think
colleges are basically for fun and to
prove that you can do your chores but
they're not for learning dang it's true
right it's so true people just go there
and party they get all this money from
their loans and they don't spend it on
because they don't value some Avett let
me let me tell you a lesson real quick
yeah they don't tell you it that's true
exactly you know you know what the first
thing they tell you when you're slinging
CDs you play music you record your own
music the one thing you never do is give
it away for free you know why you'll see
people on the street they'll be handing
out CDs they always charge because
people who can hand something for free
don't value it correct so what happens
you get a kid no probably never worked
these kids might have a summer job at
some point they go to college before
ever working and they're like oh by the
way we're going to give you 40 grand you
got
ass back and they're like I have 40
grand awesome yep not gonna kick out my
room with all this cool stuff
not even that the people I knew when to
the bar yeah like I'm gonna so decide
when to go to the bars like you got to
pay that money back with interest you
know right every single friend of mine
that went to college that I went to
visit to like we went to different dorm
rooms that showed me around each dorm
room I've ever been into had a liquor
cabinet that was stopped like it's not
like liquors expensive four or five
bottles of liquor full but the big huge
bottles it isn't expensive unless
they're drinking it every single day
there's a party man they're going
through it exact a waste of time he's
right so here's what here's why I love
this this are learn anything on your own
so this is an article from just the news
I guess this is John Solomon's thing
isn't it is that news yeah so so you
know why I like this article mmm because
I can tell people all day and night
college to waste time for most people
it's a waste time and yet they do well
you're the exception to not the rule you
know most people need to go to college
so they can get a job and I'm like brow
if Elon Musk is gonna say it to your
face yeah like how many people need to
say it to you until you get it through
your head that you need skills going to
school is a college for most things is a
waste of time yeah especially today when
knowledge is free yeah exactly you know
this look at this thing here look at see
this can I get a look at see look this
is a phone it has everything on it
there's an access anything that we have
we can access at any library any
anything all the stuff I can learn
everything on this little device you
know my favorite my favorite jokes as
though my favorite jokes is there was a
post on Reddit and they said if you can
go back in time a hundred years and tell
tell someone something that would shock
them what would you say and one of the
top comments was I hold in my hand a
device which grants me access to the
summation of human knowledge you know I
use it to look at pictures of cats and
argue with strangers yeah that's what we
do it's all there is that actually side
sides that there's a story today from
the Daily Mail that videos of cats is
it's our up 40 million views or
something over the past year whoa
because people are playing videos of its
videos four cats four cats four cats to
watch to watch like
Birds doing bird stuff and like you play
it you put it over your head but hold on
hold on hold on this is it this is this
is in in theme with with it with a
segment we're doing do you have any idea
how much money these people are making
the ads or they put it they put a camera
yeah they put a camera outside and they
they put on a little mount and they put
seeds in front of it and they just leave
it there and they come back later in the
day and they take the camera and sure
enough there's a bunch of birds chirp
and a bunch of squirrels nibbling on
nuts and they upload it and it's a
two-hour long video and they're gonna
put default ads in it and they're gonna
make thousands of dollars off that why
do we not do that yeah what are we
waiting for
no no no we got is really cool birds out
there man and the people who are doing
it probably have a degree they will
never use that's a good point and
they're making all this money or or half
of them don't have a degree and they're
still making all that money I'd be
willing to bet it's a lot people know
degrees because the people that I know
that got degrees don't have jobs in
their degrees Yeah right
they have good jobs they make good money
they have like their dream jobs and it
had nothing to do with what they went to
school for you know my favorite thing is
though like the people that I tend to
work with mmm like like I'll hire our
contract out you know college degrees
and they're better at it but one thing I
really love cuz I'll gloat on this it's
like they I've heard from friends that
I've like hired for contract jobs like
hey we're gonna do a film like when I
worked for like you know the other media
companies I worked for we yeah and then
they get to brag about how like all my
friends went to college I really angry I
got this big you know this deal and it's
like they argue it's cause you have
connections and also other other excuses
and I'm like they were about connection
they were good at video production
producing story writing you know I hired
him exactly and they wasted their time
going to school while the people I hire
were working right games like real
experience if you're somebody who at 18
went out and filmed and edited skate
videos you will be a better video editor
yep then someone went to school for it
yeah I got a buddy I mean typically
non-stop making videos non-stop and they
went from being like this random crazy
videos to now he's mean he makes so many
and like now they're really starting to
come around he's writing his screenplays
he's non-stop and you know he he's got a
good he's got his parents kind of pay
for stuff and but he's non-stop
and he's I know a lot of people that
kind of give him you know I say chatty
for it and he's just like now I'm gonna
do this and he's getting better and dude
he's gonna make like a list movies one
day I'm fairly certain he won't go to
college you know he's it's not even it's
it's it's not to say that if you got
going on it going at it doing it
non-stop it's not to say that if you go
to college you can't become good no
that's true I mean I like it I know
people that did go to school for
business and now they're running
businesses so it's like alright there is
the few time so it does make sense
you're gonna spend four years mmm
dragging behind people who spend four
years like so let's say you want to be a
video editor and I said it because
that's what I know like you know one of
the best things I don't so you guys I'm
gonna go to school for it take out loans
for it what do you think you're gonna be
four years later when your other buddy
just started making short films putting
them on YouTube dude after four years of
working everyday and producing videos as
often as you can you're gonna have it
you're very likely to have a good
following on YouTube true you're very
likely to have a couple made neighbors
maybe successes but more importantly
you'll have a real you'll have a
production real you have you'll have
something in your resume in portfolio to
be like here's the stuff I've done over
four years you'll work with your friends
you'll make real things and I tell you
what I haven't even been doing YouTube
for four years full-time and and I've
made it work and if you go to school
instead you're gonna be behind the curve
and in debt and now you get must saying
but here there's some other stuff I
won't agree when he brings up [ __ ] he
says right here he said musk dropped out
of doctorate program at Stanford 95 then
named a bunch of successful individuals
who didn't finish college yeah he said
gay he didn't even finish Bill Gates he
says his smart guy he dropped out before
he to Microsoft Jobs was pretty smart he
dropped out Larry Ellison smart guy he
dropped out obviously not needed so did
Shakespeare even go to college
probably not yeah must told the audience
that he wants to see humans go to Mars
before he dies but that's what will
happen I hope I'm not dead by the time
people go to Mars that'd be a great
great outcome I think I might be you
know if we don't improve our pace of
progress I'm definitely you know going
to be dead before we go to Mars it's
done so if it's taking us 18 years just
to get ready to be the first people to
orbit we better improve our rate of
innovation or you know based on past
trends I am definitely gonna be dead
before Mars so we've got to improve our
pace of innovation so
anyway the mars thing is interesting to
mom I mean if it if it stays in the
private sector and he he goes there
himself that makes more sense well I
don't think he can and I base X is is
big enough
I think the Mars thing is an aside you
know to keep it on point he brings up
all of these people I've succeeded and
he keeps saying but he brings to the
most important part did Shakespeare go
to college how many people that we look
to in history that we think were great
people had no formal education a lot my
favorite author I never went to school
he never graduated high school boom
there you go yeah boom and so we look
back at these historical figures and
we're like we must go to school to be
great it's like dude nobody from history
this school didn't even exist yeah how
did these people become great school is
the trick man they became great by
persistence at the thing they were good
at oh no no that became good from the
persistence
it was the perseverance that brought a
bold combo well some people were
naturally gifted but like you know it's
the persistence that makes it shine over
everyone else that's also good yeah you
know it's all that really comes down to
is if you spend time in the real world
actually doing something you are gonna
be infinitely more valuable than someone
who goes to school for it yep it is a
tendency not you know they say it's the
exception that if you drop out of school
like they say you know these people like
jobs gates etc well those are the
exception not the rule the rule is you
have to go to school the wise you don't
succeed it's not the case yeah it feels
the you're right except the people who
drop out end up succeeding and what
happens as they look to like high school
rates and they're like but look the
average person who dropped out of high
school you know fails they don't make
any money it's like no no no you're
conflating a lack of perseverance and
commitment right with dropping out you
can drop out because you you you have
Drive and you say this is wasting my
time and it's in my way get on my way
yeah but you're looking at the people
who are like I don't know oh well I
don't care I don't know I don't care to
further myself right and that's the
thing that's why they drop out and so
you have the issue of if you know what
you want to do and you want to do it
drop out you know if you don't know what
you want to do and you have no idea
where you're going don't go to college
because then you're gonna be in debt and
clueless and still not know where you
still do but you know I tell people
exactly I asked him this like a bunch of
my friends asked me like when they say
like I don't know what I want
do and I'll say what were you doing when
you were 13 what were you doing when you
were 13 I was living in the same area
probably with a stack of magic cards
sitting at the you know school table
playing with my buddies I had no idea
what I wanted to do though so no idea
well I still don't want to know what I
want to do when I grow up well so well
you're you're more than a grown up hey
did your birthday
no nobody hears I tell people like
you've got to think about what you were
doing in a young age and find something
in that space because you will probably
you're more likely to find your passion
hmm in what used to do so I should start
a game company I like this right I like
this and maybe yes maybe I already have
and so I was basically doing very much
the same things I've always ever done
but it's always been a bit random making
making YouTube videos I was making skate
videos that counts right and I was doing
video editing and I was doing internet
stuff I was reading online yeah I used
to go online and read my entire life's
all I did because we had the internet
now go online ongoing chat rooms I'd go
to websites I would read I had my own
geocities website I was on social media
I used to start my started making flash
games and flash animations cool and I
start doing skate videos and all of that
has become a peripheral to what I
actually do
yes reading news online going on social
media and making videos it's literally
what I was doing when I was funny when I
was 13 I was hanging out with my friends
and playing video games and that I still
feel like that's somebody like this now
right because I'm hanging out with my
friend I get to chat about random stuff
well so here great so so here's what I
tell people though mm-hmm
likes I was thinking about professional
athletes like well they've been playing
baseball since they were little kids
true they love playing baseball yeah
yeah and so I was talking my friend and
I was like she was saying she did know
what she wanted to do and I said what
were you doing you're 13 she's like just
hanging off my friends all day and like
watching TV and I was like how would you
love to own your own bar it was like oh
that would be amazing
I'm like exactly I'm not saying sitting
around doing nothing with your friends
is a good thing but you can create
something that's valuable to other
people yeah and can can fit that thing
that you were doing so for me I was
being productive and I'm doing very much
the same thing I was doing when I was
little
if you just want to sit around hang out
with your buddies and watch TV open a
bar or work at a bar a sports bar oh
you're funny baby you're gonna be
hanging out with your locals talking
about you know whatever TV's on there's
gonna be snacks and drinks and that
sounds fun yeah like you know yeah
that's that's my secret but if you if
you think going to school and being a
drone because that's basically buddy
says it proves that you're good at doing
your chores
yeah and that's gonna create value for a
business you are your so I think it
feels like it's not creating leaders
just it's creating more sheeple unite
following the curb follow why would it
the path why would a company want to
hire that exactly that's why you I was
like why do that we need leaders that
are innovating not people that just
follow what they're told that's not
gonna progress humanity yep but college
is a great scam with predatory lending
practices massive student debt you know
and a bunch of young people who are now
so desperate they feel the only answer
is to have the government do it for them
yeah that's a problem true that anyway
I'll leave with my final advice oh if
you're a young person and you don't what
you want to do the last thing you should
do is go to college because then you're
gonna be four years later not knowing
what you want to do and in debt yeah and
then you're gonna have no choice and
you're gonna back well I better go work
at Starbucks otherwise I can't pay off
my loans mm-hm and then you'll never get
to do anything fun thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you